[Musique]
samedi premier jour d'ouverture du
centre vacciner à la bge et je le sais
parce que c'est dans la ville et il
dépend de la municipalité
vous savez quand il n'y avait pas que ça
allait samassa 20 accès plutôt qu'à
mettre en place une chaîne logistique
valable plutôt qu'à se préparer à
diffuser le vaccin dans toute la france
ils ont comparé ont consacré leur
énergie à de la rhétorique et de
l'idéologie à une croisade contre le
couple complotisme et l'obscurantisme
c'est pas le sujet alors finalement la
campagne suscitent plus d'engouement que
prévu et le site est déjà saturée ce
matin l adhésion au vaccin monte à elle
est même majoritaire maintenant 54 % des
français ont l'intention de recevoir
cette injection
ce ne sera pas oublié l'échec du
gouvernent tout ça tout ça nous fera pas
oublier l'échec du gouvernement vous
êtes leterrier je suis et moi si je peux
finir une phrase c'est à dire au moins
je vais prendre un café je reviens dans
5000 no no no no no no manifestement il
y a un effet sur la circulation du virus
de l'avancement du couvre-feu à 18
heures et ce qui nous a été démontrée ce
matin à l'appui de données
et de statistiques c'est que dans les
départements où le couvre-feu a été
avancée à 18h au tout début du mois de
janvier la circulation du virus est
moins importante que dans d'autres
départements français rouvrir tous
mais est-ce qu'il ya eu un cluster dans
les cinémas et dans les théâtres est-ce
qu'il ya trop de risques non non mais
que vous souhaitiez tous fermés tous
mariés mais mange chaud tel secret c'est
de jouer si vos droits sociaux autre
ligue a voté la scission
vous avez manqué le début de cette
interview vous souhaitiez assumer des
positions personnelles donc agita les
petites a pris la défense du verdon
geci pratique sur l'ensemble dû
territoire métropolitain
le couvre-feu s'appliquera à compter de
18 heures à partir de ce samedi et pour
au moins 15 jours passaient pas comme ça
que j'imaginais ma vie étudiante
je suis tout seul je peux pas voir mes
amis les seuls contacts que j'ai c'est
par message ou ou pour aller faire ma
lessive ou pour aller chercher du pain à
partir de samedi 18 heures chacun devra
être chez soi
les dérogations très limitées seront les
mêmes que celles actuellement
applicables pour le couvre-feu à 20h
pour la première fois la télévision
camille kouchner raconte le traumatisme
qu'elle et son frère jumeau ont subi
durant leur adolescence dans son livre
choc la familia grande et elle accuse
son beau père olivier duhamel professeur
de droit solaire et influente field
hésité à me serrer la main
il était le camp du bien le camp du
juste ouais j'espère un espèce de
provincial plouc en plus à droite de la
droite quasi fasciste sire que ces gens
là non seulement ils ont des
comportements abominable dégueulasse
dégueulasse mais en plus il se
prétendait où c'est ce qu'ils vont nous
donner des leçons
moi j'ai une âme terre pendant des
années avant 30 ans de silence
maintenant je trouve que le silence il
est pour lui c'est un pas une histoire
de punition c'est justement là qu'il
entende que c'est impardonnable et que
ça va durer toute la vie
l'hommage à gauche à droite est unanime
pour saluer cette femme très droite
voici l'hommage de françois bayrou
voici le jour entre au marielle si
talentueuse et si courageuse marielle de
sarnez vient de partir notre chagrin est
immense
nous avons besoin d'avoir d'autres
relations avec la presse telle qu'elle
existe non pas pour poser sur ses
contenus
nous n'avons pas cette idée ni pour
exiger je ne sais quel flair tri mais
pour créer une autre relation
élu député marielle de sarnez devient
alors présidente de la commission des
affaires étrangères de l'assemblée
elle s'est éteinte à 69 ans d'une
leucémie foudroyante veut pas mourir
c'est juste un tour rapide par question
et je croyais que vous deviez vous
changez votre gentil avec les journal
jeunes obligés pas promis chat si vous
avez changé votre relation avec la
presse
oui c'est à dire que on va avoir une
relation